the cast of the Huntsman winters war at
their movie's premiere in Singapore
Charlize Theron another day another
stunning outfit that white dress is Dior
because I know fashion Nancy you just
want to let you know last summer I
actually traveled to London while they
were filming and was blown away but wait
until you see these costumes I have the
story behind these amazing one-of-a-kind
creations is it like the ultimate
dress-up oh yeah I've never done
anything like this I mean the fantasy
element of this really allows us to
really push it that fantasy comes to
life in the extraordinary costumes
created by three-time Academy Award
winner Colleen Atwood Colleen and her
team crafted more than a thousand ornate
designs for the film the tiniest little
details from like how the beading is on
these three had little stripes I mean
it's just incredible I got a personal
tour of Colleen's massive shop outside
of London it's where Emily silver
metallic gown which is actually made of
leather took three full-time workers a
month to make I wanted something equal
to the feathered cloak that Charlie's
whereas I'm stronger than all of you
now you go gold we want gold it's black
feathers that are gold leaf Colleen
created the costumes for the 2012
Huntsman film and didn't want to repeat
yourself we wanted to do the cloak again
we're like it can't be black I can't it
because so we did it this is char Lisa's
costume she wears in the entrance of the
final act when she comes out of the gold
mirror in this dress
the fairest Colleen glammed up this blue
gown for Charlize with a very unique
accessory
she wears a amazing headdress with and
his chains are gonna go in front of her
face and her Jessica Chastain's warrior
character the designs also practically
she's made me this incredible costume
but knowing there's a lot of waiting to
she's created film crew meanwhile all
Chris Hemsworth needed was comfort does
it get hot in that thing it does yeah
leather doesn't tend to breathe some
reason they need to be able to move and
do all kinds of action with an actor
with a stunt double because they do a
lot of high kicks and climbing and
action what Colleen Atwood did with
these costumes is magical giver to ask
her now she'll go to Tibet for the
rights of leather over an outfit before
I'm all in I love it